لا تزال عمليات ازاله الركام مستمره في
مدينه دنيترو بعد الهجوم الذي تعرض له
مجمع سكني وخلف عشرات الضحايا والمصابين
وترك ايضا اثاره على وجوه الناجين
ووجدانهم اذ ما يزال البعض منهم يعاني
الصدمه من ما حدث
كنت جالسا في غرفتي اقرب بعض الكتب لم
اسمع صوت الانفجار وكانه موجه تنقذتني
استيقظته فوجدت نفسي مدرج الدماء
تسبب الهجوم في تدمير 230 شقه وفق السلطات
المحليه التي تسعى لازاله كل العثرات في
سبيل البحث عن ناجي
بعض البيوت المجاوره التي تعرضت لدمار
الجزئي يسعى اهلها
وامها الى ازالته بسرعه
باذى اشكر كل ما يقدم يد العون كنا
محذوفين على عكس اخرين اذ لم نفقد احد
تكشف الماساه عن وجه اخر قد يكون مشرقا
تتجلى فيه صور للتكافل
افراد ومنظمات يسعون لتخفيف اللعب عن
المتضررين عبر تقديم كل انواع المساعدات
سيكون لهذا الهجوم انعكاسات بلا شك كما
تقول جينا ولربما سيدفع البعض الى الرحيل
كممرضه وكمواطنه اوكرانيه ولان الوضع خطير
جدا
كانت هذه المحطه الاخيره في حياه من رحلوا
في هذا الهجوم وان كان الحزن قد ملا وجوه
احبائهم
لكنه هناك وجوها اخرى تظهر الامل على
استحياء
تركض اي خبر مفرح عن من بقي محاصرا وان
كانت ملامح المشهد لا تبشر بالكثير
عن سقوط الصاروخ فوق هذا المبنى السكني
وما تزال حقيقه ما حدث غامضه حتى الان لكن
حقيقه اخرى باتت واضحه فقد شرد كثيرون من
بيوتهم قتل اخرون ليتحولوا الى مجرد ارقام
في هذه الحرب التي يبدوها لن تطفئها بروده
الشتاء
عمر حاج الجزيره